[Applause]
that's Kate Middleton showing off her
athletic prowess again last week the
Duchess of Cambridge sprinted her heart
out
and practiced her punches during a visit
to the sports aid charity and on
Thursday the 38 year old royal and her
hubby Prince William tried out a few
Irish sports during their visit to the
Gaelic Athletic Association in Galway
here they are practicing their Gaelic
football skills and they proved to be
Naturals at hurling
after a few false starts William and
Kate were able to score the Duchess of
Cambridge looked every bit the athlete
she is sporting a cherry red sweater
black jeans and New Balance sneakers for
the occasion earlier in the day William
and Kate watched members of the Galway
circus put their skills on display
afterwards the 37 year old Duke proved
he can juggle Kate opened up about the
talents of her two eldest kids revealing
that six-year-old George is starting to
learn the guitar and four year old
Charlotte is really into gymnastics
adding quote she's doing cartwheels
handstands everything
[Music]
Thursday marks the third and final day
of william and kate's a royal tour of
Ireland which has overall been a pretty
active one the couple played ping pong
during a visit to Dublin savanna house
on Wednesday kate revealing this about
their family games back home the couple
also found time to take a romantic
stroll along the cliffs of Dublin where
cameras caught several rare moments of
PDA
William and Kate will return to the UK
after today's events they're set to
publicly reunite with Prince Harry and
his wife Megan Markel on Monday for the
Commonwealth Day service at Westminster
Abbey Monday is going to be bittersweet
in a sense for the royal family it's our
last opportunity to see the Fab Four all
together they're going to be at the
Commonwealth Day service but it is of
course going to represent Harry and
Megan's last official engagement as
senior members of the royal family it's
the last time we'll see them in an
official capacity with William and Kate
with Charles and Camilla and of course
the Queen so in some ways it's going to
be an exciting time for Harry and Megan
because after the Commonwealth Service
they get to enjoy this next chapter in
their new lives but for the rest of the
royal family I think they're going to
leave an irreplaceable void and they'll
be missed tremendously
[Music]